il veut retourner chez sa mère et ben ça
tombe bien parce que ta valise elle est
prête et ben voilà il laisse tomber
comme des vieilles chaussettes mais
comment ça je vous laisse tomber comme
des vieilles chaussettes mais madame Tha
mais c'est vous qui m'avez dit de partir
je te dis de partir et toiis tu par
cétait un test un test oui un test c'est
une histoire vieille de pratiquement 40
ans le cirque bidon un cirque vraiment
pas comme les autres ni traditionnel ni
contemporain on est plutôt dans un
spectacle de sainttinbanque un cirque
authentique poétique et original qui
trouve son origine dans une histoire
tout aussi originale une histoire
d'amour après 68 j'ai quitté Paris j'ai
voyagé et j'ai rencontré une en province
dans les bois une une trapészisse qui
était arrêté et qui qui qui en avait
marre de travailler dans les grands
cirques et qui voulait et qui rêvait
d'un cirque différent un un petit
cirquele très poétique romantique et
pourquoi pas avec des rouottes et des
chevaux l'histoire d'amour s'est depuis
arrêté mais le CIRC lui a continué un
mélange de numéros traditionnels de
chant et de la comédie à la limite du
vaudeville derrière une compagnie de 14
personnes tous s'habitent et se déplace
de ville en ville en roulotte alors les
tout est vraiment très bien conçu pour
ne pas perdre du tout de de place bien
sûr parce que c'est un petit lieu donc
il y a des tiroirs on peut tirer et et
qui vont qui font toute la surface du
lit derrière j'en ai et j'en ai deux et
et plein de fenêtres partout ça fait
quand il fait très chaud j'ouvre toutes
les fenêtres j'ai des courants d'air des
roulottes qui servent aussi de décor
pour le spectacle un spectacle que cette
chanteuse comédienne a découvert en tant
que spectatrice elle en est tombée
amoureuse et y travaille désormais
depuis de saisons j'ai toujours rêveré
de de de jouer de ville en ville alors
j'imaginais même pas dans des roulotes
mais là c'est encore plus magnifique
quoi et puis c'est un spectacle très
particulier je me souviens quand je l'ai
vu sous les étoiles avec voilà on a le
le ciel en toile de fond on a
l'impression d'un voyage dans le
[Musique]
cosmos il fera beau ce soir la nouvelle
création bidon l'histoire une troupe de
cirque qui subit de plein fois le
conflit de génération d'un côté des
jeunes qui réclament plus de confort de
l'autre des anciens qui refusent tout
changement
ch vous voulez pas non plus un pavillon
dans le 16e avec piscine en terrasse
attendiez à ça ou pas du tout pas tout
on n pas envie d'aller voir un autre CC
après quoi j'ai l'impression que je
reviens en enfance j'ai 5 ans et mag
poésie en plus au niveau technique ils
sont très fort très bien ça va vraiment
le
détour
journée des comédiens qui jouent
constamment leur rôle même à l'accueil
du public et un moment inoubliable pour
le spectateur petit ou grand des
représentations sont programmées tout
l'été en indr Loire et Loire etcher et
c'est sur ces images que l'on referme ce
journal La des
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ern